depuis quelques semaines les
observatoires du monde entier braquent
leurs télescopes sur mars l'inquiétante
planète rouge et berne à la surface de
laquelle on a distingué une ap de vapeur
que certains ont assimilé à une
formidable explosion
il n'en fallait pas plus pour
ressusciter le mythe de l'existence des
martiens nos aînés d'un milliard
d'années et distant seulement de 70
millions de kilomètres aussitôt on s'est
souvenu de ce pilote de l'aviation
américaine qui déconne en deux nuits le
1er octobre 49 1 bêta perte une classe
est bizarre dans le ciel suivie de
l'apparition d'une soucoupe volante
il avait eu le temps de détailler pas
mal mieux avant de disparaître le nom
bornes at-il été la première victime des
mafias
bien improbable mais si la guerre des
mondes n'est pas pour demain
les projets c'est l'accord laissant
prévoir pour bientôt le premier voyage
dans la lune et on nous affirme déjà
qu'avant disant on verra dimanche à
hirgars sidéral assurer le départ des
fusées interplanétaire
on reprendra son billet tout
naturellement pour le week end
histoire de voir ce qui se passe là où
les voyageurs pour la lune en voiture
la tour de contrôle faire un signal
rotax
les touristes sidéré le nez collé au
houblon des mandataires s'amenuiser puis
disparaître à la vitesse de huit ou dix
mille kilomètres heure tandis que la
lune se rapprochera à vue d'oeil à l'une
romantique des clair de lune et menthe
ou presque
la nouvelle lune
non